donc bonsoir Monsieur le Ministre donc
nous avons une audition d'une heure
puisque à la suite de votre intervention
madame Ségolène Royal
occupera votre siège donc merci d'avoir
répondu à notre demande donc monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues donc nous entendons
aujourd'hui véritablement les travaux de
la commission d'enquête sur l'efficacité
des politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique et nous avons
choisi de débuter par une série
d'auditions et des anciens responsables
politiques du secteur dans ce cadre nous
vous accueillons ce soir en votre
qualité d'anciens ministres de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur le ministre vous avez été
député à partir de 2007 et avait exercé
les fonctions de président de
l'Assemblée nationale de 2017 à 2018
puis de ministres de septembre 2018 à
juillet 2019 dans le le gouvernement
d'Edouard Philippe cette période a été
plus particulièrement marquée par la
préparation et le vote de la loi
relative à l'énergie et au climat
finalement adopter début novembre 2019
et par les lancements de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat et du Conseil de
défense écologique annoncé par le
président de la République en avril 2019
c'est donc une période particulièrement
riche et importante pour notre sujet et
vous en êtes en tout cas vous en avez
été un acteur et un témoin de premier
plan la commission souhaitera donc
savoir le bilan que vous tirez de votre
passage au gouvernement
quelles sont vos principaux motifs de
satisfaction et quelles sont au
contraire vos regrets les sujets sur
lesquels vous auriez souhaité aller plus
loin dans ce cas quels ont été les
obstacles que que vous avez rencontré il
nous sera également particulièrement
intéressant qu'avec votre expérience
vous puissiez nous partager votre
jugement de la politique menée depuis
votre départ du gouvernement et votre
analyse des raisons pour lesquelles
certains objectifs de la loi énergie
climat n'ont pas été atteints par
ailleurs la convention citoyenne pour le
climat a favoriser une mobilisation et
l'émergence d'idées mais au final qu'en
est-il resté est-ce la bonne méthode le
rapport sechel n'a-t-il pas finalement
joué un rôle plus important dans le
volet rénovation de la loi climat et
résilience que la convention citoyenne
elle-même
quel regard portez-vous enfin sur le
Conseil national de la refondation qui
lui a qui lui a succédé au regard de
votre expérience les blocages et les
insuffisances de la rénovation
énergétique dans notre pays sont-ils
liés à un manque de financement à des
questions de règlementation de méthode
ou à une prise de conscience
insuffisante des enjeux ou encore de
vision à long terme et de constance
voilà monsieur le ministre je ne veux
pas allonger la liste de ses premières
questions qui sont déjà bien complètes
et qui seront très certainement
approfondies par notre rapporteur mais
aussi par les collègues qui assistent à
cette audition et qui sont membres de
notre commission d'enquête avant de vous
laisser la parole pour y répondre et
pour un propos introductif d'une
quinzaine de minutes il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et fera l'objet
d'un compte-rendu publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de 3 ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc monsieur le ministre a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure
je le jure merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez maintenant la parole
si jamais il y a des demandes plus
précises vous me permettrait d'aller
chercher mes lunettes que j'ai oublié
dans mon manteau
oui si vous voulez comme ça ça fera pas
d'interruption excusez-moi
excusez moi alors avant de je sais pas
si je pourrais répondre à toutes les
questions que vous avez déjà posé madame
la Présidente je déclenche en même temps
un compteur dans votre propos
introductif mais cela toute façon
rejoint je pense les réflexions que
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments des logements
se posent
j'en ajouterai d'ailleurs une ou deux à
mon tour je pense que sur ces politiques
là comme sur d'autres mais c'est
particulièrement vrai sur les sujets
écologiques il faut aussi se poser la
question de savoir si ce que l'on
recherche c'est ce qui est le plus
efficace et donc de déterminer aussi ce
qui est efficace le nombre de tonnes de
de économiser chaque année l'énergie
économisée CO2 ou pas ou ce que l'on
recherche c'est ce qui est le plus
symbolique ou le plus efficace
médiatiquement ou politiquement ou dans
les débats politicaux médiatique on
permettrait de penser que ce que l'on
devrait rechercher c'est ce qui est le
plus efficace même si ce n'est pas
forcément ce qui est le plus ce qui a le
plus de succès médiatique ou politique
mais quand on est ministre d'abord
parler de mon expérience de milice on
est sans cesse
confronté à
cette double entrée dans le débat si je
puis dire et je constate d'ailleurs en
étant resté un observer un observateur
attentif même si j'ai pris un peu de
distance avec la responsabilité
politique nationale que ce double
questionnement n'a pas changé
permettrait même de penser que
malheureusement le plus symbolique
l'emporte largement et très souvent sur
le plus efficace il y a aussi une
question de fond récurrente également
est-ce que on recherche des politiques
plutôt incitatives ou est-ce que l'on
recherche ou en tout cas on accepte des
politiques plus contraignantes des
obligations légales réglementaires
est-ce que on accepte des contraintes
fiscales la question de la taxe carbone
qui était très très vive lorsque j'étais
ministre puisque vous en souvenez
c'était au moment où il y a le mouvement
des gilets jaunes mais il y a aussi d'un
point de vue fiscal des incitations
crédit d'impôts divers et variés j'y
reviendrai car ça a été un des bas très
vif quand j'étais et du point de vue des
obligations réglementaires légales
législatif on voit bien que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est souvent difficile
à faire accepter notamment sur ces
sujets et on a eu des exemples très
concrets et puis il y a un troisième
questionnement un peu général qui je
crois tout le temps aussi toutes ces
politiques c'est est-ce que l'on croit
que l'efficacité vient d'une certaine
constance dans la politique monnaie dans
le temps ou est-ce qu'elle vient du fait
qu'on est capable de changer de se
remettre sans cesse en question et tant
de changer de dispositif ma conviction
est que il faut combiner l'incitation et
l'obligation l'incitation seule ne
marche pas ne suffit pas à atteindre des
objectifs importants l'obligation seule
évidemment rencontre trop de résistance
chez les citoyens tout simplement et on
devrait privilégier davantage de
Constance
et on devrait avoir davantage la mémoire
de ce qui a été fait ce qui a marché ou
n'a pas marché car j'ai constaté y
compris quand j'étais ministre que des
choses que j'avais vu passer dans un
sens ou dans l'autre lorsque j'étais
député dans ton savait que telle ou
telle chose marchait plus ou moins de
telle ou tel point de vue ou marcher
moins bien et bien on continuait à
vouloir essayer en quelque sorte et à
changer l'exemple plus battant et les
effets de balancier sur les crédits
d'impôts ça c'est extrêmement clair il y
a aussi un autre une autre chose qu'il
faut toujours avoir en tête c'est que
contrairement à ce que croit je le dis
d'autant plus que c'est public et que
c'est retransmis est-ce que croit
beaucoup de citoyens une idée que
propage aussi beaucoup de responsables
politiques malheureusement et en tout
cas de médias ça c'est sûr les hommes et
les femmes politiques qui sont élus que
ce soit le président de la République ou
plus haut niveau soit les ministres
qu'il a nommé et qui donc
qui sont en responsabilité en son nom ou
les députés d'une majorité cherchent à
mettre en oeuvre les promesses
électorales qu'ils ont faites et en ce
domaine il y en avait puisque vous en
souvenez en 2017 il y avait la promesse
de ne pas mettre enfin de sortir du
marché de la location les passoires
thermiques comme souvent les promesses
électorales ne sont pas définies très
clairement et très précisément d'un
point de vue technique ou sur les moyens
d'y parvenir et c'est évidemment là
dessus que nous sommes heurtés à
beaucoup de difficultés puis il y a
aussi une autre chose qui intervient
toujours qui est le contexte budgétaire
et donc tout cela évidemment sous tendu
mon action qui pourtant pour ce qui est
du gouvernement ne s'est déroulé que sur
10 mois alors sur pour être un peu plus
concret à partir de cette partie là je
veux bien répondre évidemment des
questions sur ce qui a pu se passer
avant ou après déjà sous le premier
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron et où depuis où
même avance ou d'autres mandats d'autres
présidents de la République d'autres
gouvernements
nous avons moi quand j'ai été nommé
ministre j'ai été confronté tout de
suite à un sujet de négociation
budgétaire puisque j'ai été nommé tout
début du mois de septembre et donc le
budget
de loi de finance allait être présentée
dans les jours qui suivaient par le
gouvernement en conseil des ministres
puis au Parlement et il y avait un débat
à l'époque entre le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances son ministre le
ministre chargé des comptes publics
comme on dit et moi-même mais mon
prédécesseur avait également mené ce
débat sur ce qu'il devait advenir du
crédit d'impôt transition énergétique et
surtout de ce que l'on devait mettre
dedans
un double débat sur le volume
inutile de vous dire que les ministres
budgétaires on va les appeler ainsi
veuillez plutôt réduire le volume et
comme vous le savez dans ces cas-là
plutôt que de le dire aussi brutalement
on dit que l'on va resserrer les
critères que l'on va les resserrer
d'ailleurs d'un point de vue écologique
et d'un point de vue social ça j'ai
appris que les budgétaires savent bien
manier reprendre les arguments de ceux
qu'ils ont en face de sur le fond pour
expliquer qu'ils font ça au nom de
l'écologie et de la solidarité que donc
il ne faudrait pas subventionner
impôts des actions même si elles sont
pour de la rénovation énergétique des
logements si c'est des gens qui auraient
les moyens de le faire sans cela donc ça
c'est resserrer les critères du point de
vue des personnes bénéficiaires et puis
d'un point de vue écologique de dire que
alors on appelle ça parfois les gestes
je trouve ça un peu bizarre c'est plus
que des gestes les travaux qui sont les
moins efficaces ne doivent plus être
subventionnés et je ne sais pas si vous
en souvenez mais à l'époque il y avait
un gros débat sur les fenêtres et donc
quand j'ai des mises j'ai dû gérer si je
peux vous dire la crise des fenêtres
puisque
il avait été déjà de fait négocier avant
que j'arrive que l'on sorte les fenêtres
des subventions possibles de crédits
d'impôt au motif que cela était le moins
efficace du point de vue de la baisse de
la consommation d'énergie ou des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et là
on sans être tout de suite dans le
symbolique ou l'efficacité de fait il y
a aussi un ressenti pour beaucoup de
gens le premier ressenti première chose
auquel il pense pour l'efficacité
énergétique c'est les fenêtres pour une
raison simple mais je crois que c'était
important de savoir ce que les gens ont
en tête quand ils font un choix c'est
que quand vous approchez une fenêtre en
simple vitrage d'une fenêtre de dégradée
ou de ancienne et bien vous sentez le
froid en hiver tout simplement c'est
aussi bête que ça et donc vous dites si
on met du double vitrage on aura quelque
chose qui sera plus agréable et c'est ce
ressenti et puis par ailleurs c'est les
travaux les plus simples à faire et à
commander et évidemment les artisans du
bâtiment et leur fédération ont fait une
grosse action pour expliquer que c'était
la pire des choses que de sortir les
fenêtres du crédit d'impôt moi j'ai
contribué à dire qu'en effet c'était un
peu brutal de les sortir plus ou moins
simplement et j'avais en mémoire
et bien évidemment on va avoir moins de
gens et il faut que ce soit accessible
donc à la fois type de travaux et en
personne assez largement
parce que si on dit qu'on va faire des
crédits d'impôts même si c'est des
crédits d'impôts c'est pas des
réductions d'impôts donc tout le monde
peut en bénéficier même ceux qui ne
payent pas d'impôts pour les gens qui
ont les plus faibles moyens et qu'on dit
on le réserve à eux on a très peu de
travaux qui se font puisque les gens qui
sont prêts à se lancer dans les travaux
sur leur logement c'est en général des
gens qui sont déjà dans des tranches
fiscales plus élevées voilà alors après
on peut dire oui mais on va subvention
des gens qui ont les moyens oui mais
est-ce que l'on veut avoir des résultats
ou pas voilà et après c'est vrai que
chaque année on peut quand même ça c'est
facile à évaluer puisqu'on sait combien
il y a eu de chantiers ces petits
chantiers de rénovation énergétique qui
ont été faits donc ça c'était un premier
sujet lorsque j'ai été nommé ministre
tout de suite et si vous voulez je
pourrais revenir mais ces deux là
d'ailleurs qui est né l'idée qu'il
fallait réformer le système et ensuite
ça a donné lieu j'en étais plus ministre
mais j'y avais travaillé j'avais préparé
cela ma prime rénove et donc un autre
type de dispositif d'ailleurs j'ai bien
vu qu'après le dispositif d'après mis en
place quoi qu'on était déjà dans l'idée
mais il est assez large est-ce que parce
qu'on veut entre guillemets et faire du
chiffre et ce qui est normal puisque on
veut qu'il y ait une certaine efficacité
sur la réalité de des économies
d'énergie donc ça c'était un sujet
le sujet bon de la taxe carbone je n'y
reviens pas plus que ça mais il est
évident que
à partir du moment où on envoie le
signal que l'on stoppe net une
perspective
de d'augmentation des prix des énergies
fossiles par l'attaque alors parfois
l'augmentation se fait par le marché
c'est ce qui se produit actuellement
mais à l'époque c'était pas le cas les
gens complètement oubliés mais que les
prix de l'énergie il y a 5 ans était
très bas
prix de l'électricité je tiens quand
même à le rappeler de l'électricité donc
en France décarbonée mais c'était moins
de 50 euros mégawattheure comme moi j'ai
été nommé ministre même l'année d'avance
c'était moins la reine était à 40 euros
n'était même pas intéressantes pour les
gens qui achetaient de l'électricité en
gros
donc un des moyens de donner une
perspective de dire toujours le sujet de
la constance dans la durée il faut
économiser l'énergie et il faut sortir
des énergies fossiles
c'était un outil
je pense et ça c'est malheureusement le
débat n'a plus lieu aujourd'hui il est
pas d'actualité parce que les prix des
énergies fossiles sont très élevés mais
si le remettent à baisser que on aurait
dû travailler plutôt que sur on le fait
on le fait pas on stoppe on stoppe pas
sur des mécanismes d'adaptation aux
réalités du marché bon mais de garder
cette perspective car sinon évidemment
on envoie un signal général qui n'est
pas bon pour les économies d'énergie et
la réduction des énergies fossiles je le
mets de côté puisque ça a été tranché à
l'époque et depuis ça n'a pas bougé je
crois que d'ailleurs quasiment aucun
cours en politique ne propose de bouger
sur le sujet mais c'est dommage qu'il y
ait en France une sorte de tétanie ou de
traumatisme autour de cela parce que
évidemment c'est quand même un sujet de
fond au passage parenthèse mais qui a un
lien direct avec le logement j'ai vu le
résultat immédiatement sur les réseaux
de chaleur
des projets de réseau de chaleur qui se
faisaient au bois ils sont passés au gaz
parce que d'un seul coup ils étaient
beaucoup plus rentable façon de parler
moins coûteux avec du gaz qu'avec du
bois ah oui parce que la perspective
d'augmentation de la taxe carbone sur le
gaz faisait que on savait le coup
d'aller sur du bois pour des
investissements qui s'amortit sur 20-25
ans
c'est quand même très concret tout cela
évidemment en termes de conséquences sur
l'efficacité énergétique et le climat
pour le logement nous avons eu aussi à
gérer donc la promesse faite par
Emmanuel Macron candidat à l'élection
présidentielle que j'avais soutenue donc
je me reconnaissais tout à fait dans son
programme qui était donc de sortir je
sais plus quel était la terminologie
j'ai longtemps gardé son programme mais
je ne l'ai pas avec moi mais et c'était
écrit noir sur blanc de sortir de la
location les passoires thermiques quand
on dit ça tout le monde est d'accord bon
dès qu'on commence à rentrer dans la
façon de faire là évidemment on se
heurte à les obstacles qui pour ma part
ne mettez pas inconnu j'avais déjà connu
sous un mandat précédent avec une
ministre du Logement
la membres d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
les débats sur ce sujet et j'avais vu
des associations de solidarité
ou ce type d'association dire attention
si vous faites ça vous allez sortir trop
de logements c'est des logements selon
qui sont loués à très bas prix donc les
sortir du marché ça veut dire aussi
moins de logement bon mais à l'époque
nous avons un débat au sein du
gouvernement il y a pas tellement de
débats d'ailleurs à l'époque
sur le sujet ni au Parlement ni dans
l'opinion mais enfin bon il y a cette
promesse qui a été faite donc on voit
comment la mettre en œuvre le ministre
du Logement de l'époque
globalement si oppose
une contesterait pas ce point donc on
recherche d'autres solutions
et dans la loi énergie climat dont vous
avez parlé qui a été adopté donc à
l'automne 2019 mais qui a été soumise en
première lecture au Parlement en juillet
enfin 2019 et qui que j'avais préparé en
tant que ministre
je défends l'idée d'introduire une
mesure qui ne touchait pas le marché de
la location mais le marché de la vente
l'achat avant de logement et je propose
que l'on s'inspire de quelque chose qui
existe déjà dans le droit français
qui existe pour l'assainissement vous
savez sans doute lorsqu'un logement un
assainissement non collectif il faut
sceptique pour parler trivialement qui
n'est pas aux normes soit avant la vente
de sa maison parce qu'en général c'est
des maisons individuelles bien sûr il
doit faire les travaux soit une somme
est mise sous séquestre et c'est dans
l'acte notarié donc c'est totalement
transparent pour l'acheteur comme pour
le vendeur et évidemment l'acheteur doit
faire les travaux rapidement dans un
délai en général d'un an avec cette
somme
j'ai été élu local à la communauté
urbaine de Nantes et la ville de Nantes
donc je connais parfaitement ce système
il a été mis en oeuvre d'ailleurs à
l'époque où j'étais élu donc ça
fonctionne ça a permis de traiter c'est
le cas de le dire tous les
assainissements qui n'étaient pas aux
normes donc je propose que l'on fasse un
système de même type pour les passoires
thermiques alors les logements
individuels parce que sur les logements
collectifs ça serait pas possible
lorsqu'il y a des ventes
je finis par obtenir des arbitrages
favorables du Premier ministre mais je
crois que le ministre du Logement n'y
était pas favorable non plus et je vois
fleurir à l'Assemblée nationale en
commission des amendements y compris de
députés de la majorité qui si oppose et
donc nous avons une nouvelle discussions
et finalement cette idée est abandonnée
personnellement je le regrette parce que
c'était
j'avais la paternité de cette idée mais
parce que je crois que traiter cette
question à travers le marché moi je suis
pas contre l'économie de marché bien au
contraire je pense simplement qu'il faut
l'orienter par les règles que nous
votez au Parlement et donc c'est une
façon de gérer dans le marché vous dites
pas à partir de telle date ah oui chaque
fois qu'il y a une vente et un achat bah
il y aura une mise aux normes alors il
faut aller voir jusqu'où sur parce que
c'est vrai qu'évidemment sur des
logements ça on avait sorti d'ailleurs à
l'époque je les ai pas de mémoire mais
des statistiques très précises sur quel
combien de logements et donc de
personnes derrière étaient concernés par
exemple de mémoire 500
[Musique]
maison individuelle donc passoire
thermique donc je pense que ça devait
être F et G qui était
dans les personnes propriétaires
occupantes
oui parce que dans ces cas-là on agite
les peurs il faut bien et donc on
pouvait dire bah voilà on peut aussi
évidemment accompagner aider ses 500 000
fois et sachant qu'on ne le fait pas du
jour au lendemain puisque c'est au fur
et à mesure des achats vente
je ne sais pas si cette idée reviendra
jour mais je la livre à votre réflexion
n'a pas été elle n'a pas fait Flores
depuis
et il faut le dire la promesse sur la
location a été mise en oeuvre d'une
certaine façon lors de la loi climat
résilience elle avait été renoncée
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire par la
Convention énergie enfin convention des
citoyens sur le climat et ça me permet
de d'ailleurs d'en dire un mot
cette convention nous l'avons lancé
croit pouvoir dire en être un des
en revendiquer une partie de la
paternité et nous n'étions pas très
nombreux je dois dire au sein du
gouvernement Hayette favorable je crois
que même en dehors du président de la
République et de moi-même au sein je
veux dire du de l'exécutif il y avait
personne à la défendre beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs essayé de la torpiller bon
elle a été faite et une des missions
était celle là
c'était écrit noir sur blanc dans la la
lettre de mission si on peut dire
c'est-à-dire rechercher des solutions
acceptables par les citoyens parce qu'on
voit bien qu'à chaque fois on bute sur
des questions d'acceptabilité que ce
soit pour le marché de la location ou
que ce soit pour le marché de l'achat
vente des logements
acceptable pour les citoyens sur cette
question donc de l'impact climat et on
peut dire énergétique aussi des
logements et donc le sujet de la
rénovation et je vois d'ailleurs que
nous l'avons voté non sans débat
d'ailleurs je dis nous parce que là
j'étais député à cette époque là donc je
l'ai soutenu
et qu'évidemment ce qui avait été dit ce
produit en partie c'est à dire c'est un
peu tôt pour le dire mais un certain
nombre de logements sont retirés du
marché de la location
bon on me dit aussi les professionnels
de l'immobilier disent que on les
retrouve sur le marché des ventes
d'ailleurs donc preuve que c'est
peut-être un mouvement par le biais du
marché qui est en train de se faire
parce qu'évidemment ceux qui vont devoir
les vendre pour les relouer vont devoir
et faire des travaux donc évidemment à
suivre dans l'évaluation et moi je
souhaite d'ailleurs que on fasse une
évaluation avant de changer quoi que ce
soit parce que si on fait des
changements avant d'avoir évalué on
risque pas d'avoir mesuré l'efficacité
ou les effets pervers qui peuvent
exister naturellement donc la convention
citoyenne sur le climat je pense que sur
le sujet c'est principalement ça
contribution des remarques plus générale
je pourrais emporter je cache pas que
moi j'ai été un peu déçu par les
résultats alors que j'ai porté cette
idée mais voilà sur le sujet qui vous
occupe je crois que c'était ça la chose
voilà je crois ce que je pouvais dire en
en propos général déjà assez long et sur
le fait que
je crois que on a aussi une embarque
plus générale sur le financement parce
que vous l'avez évoqué madame la
Présidente
aujourd'hui depuis quelques années
d'ailleurs on ne manque pas de
financement privé sur le sujet
on se focalise beaucoup sur le
financement public
à travers les crédits d'impôts à travers
les subventions etc oui mais enfin il
faut quand même d'abord et avant tout le
logement c'est d'abord une caution de
mobilisation de l'argent privé
à part le logement social qui fait appel
pour une part de l'argent public mais ce
qui sinon s'autofinance d'ailleurs il
faut rechercher la mobilisation soit de
l'épargne individuelle soit du crédit
bancaire nous vivons depuis quelques
années avec des taux d'intérêt très bas
cette période semble se terminer
néanmoins les taux d'intérêt restent
très inférieurs en réalité à l'inflation
donc il reste quand même
assez bas par rapport à d'autres
périodes que nous allons connues il y a
pas si longtemps donc ça c'est une
première source et je pense que les
tiers financement c'est à regarder
peut-être plus sur la des bâtiments
collectifs que sur l'habitat individuel
sont aussi à mobiliser bien sûr il y
aura toujours une part d'argent public
mais c'est pas dans l'inflation d'argent
public que l'on résoudra le problème et
il y aura toujours une part pour moi
d'obligation légale réglementaires et
c'est toujours la combinaison de ces
différents moyens en essayant d'agir
dans la durée qui à mon sens permettra
d'obtenir des résultats
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
laisser la parole à notre rapporteur
merci merci Madame ma présidente
monsieur le monsieur le ministre déjà
pour ces explications à la fois larges
et précise en tout cas sur des sur des
exemples très PC je pense qu'ils peuvent
vraiment faire avancer nos travaux
peut-être quelques quelques précisions
parce que vous avez déjà répondu à
beaucoup de choses c'est vrai que ça a
été dit donc vous avez été en charge du
texte sur NRJ et climat donc en 2019
c'est vrai que dans ce texte il y avait
déjà des éléments assez précis vous avez
un petit peu expliqué les différents
arbitrages je dirais perdu ou gagner
mais en tout cas les orientations qui
avaient été qui avaient été fait et les
questionnements dont on se pose toujours
sur effectivement comment on s'attaque
justement à cette question des passoires
thermiques et par quel dispositif et
justement est-ce qu'on a un mécanisme
plutôt coercitif ou plutôt
d'accompagnement où les deux mais en
tout cas
non c'était peut-être de voir dans les
différents dispositifs traverse ce texte
qui déjà voilà avait des ambitions assez
assez fortes peut-être les éléments sur
lequel peut-être vous regrets en tout
cas sur lequel alors vous en avez un
petit peu parlé sur notamment ce
mécanisme sur la vente qui effectivement
peut-être peut-être intéressant mais
est-ce que vous avez voilà sur les
arbitrages je dirais perdus en tout cas
sur les orientations
de vous dire maintenant regard de ce qui
a été fait et puis peut-être au regard
aussi
du texte de la loi climat sur lequel
pour le coup ça a été tranché et
notamment l'interdiction là des des
logements 1er janvier 2023 afin de la
location pour les passoires thermiques
ben voilà le regard que vous pouvez
avoir et effectivement
là on fait on verra un petit peu le
bilan de ce qu'il en est
mais peut-être des éléments en tout cas
qui vous auraient peut-être permis
d'aller peut-être plus vite et peut-être
plus plus loin sur cette sur cette
première phase ensuite peut-être une
question sur l'aspect sur l'aspect
budgétaire vous en avez aussi beaucoup
parlé c'est vrai que souvent sur la
question de la rénovation thermique
forcément c'est qu'il faut de l'argent
public privé mais en tout cas il faut il
faut de l'argent et ça nécessite
beaucoup d'argent mais on voit aussi et
c'est vrai que si on regarde les
différentes politiques publiques qui ont
été menées qui ont souvent été avec
beaucoup d'ambition et quel que soit je
dirais les ministres et les différents
gouvernements
souvent quand même avec des budgets
alors toujours se dire que c'est plus
c'est que mais que souvent se pose la
question d'efficacité en fait de
l'efficacité de cette de cet argent là
où il est mis et des résultats qu'on
peut obtenir derrière avec avec l'argent
mis en place voilà est-ce que ça a fait
partie des questionnements que vous avez
pu vous avez pu avoir et notamment à
travers les arbitrages qui ont été faits
et clairement est-ce que vous pensez que
si on avait mis beaucoup plus d'argent
est-ce qu'on serait allé beaucoup plus
vite et beaucoup plus loin
notamment après se pose la question de
la réalisation et de la possibilité qu'à
travers les à travers les entreprises
avec les capacité qu'on peut avoir sur
la question des matériaux etc mais ce
que vous pensez en tout cas est-ce que
ça a été un frein dans dans
l'application de vos politiques de vous
dire voilà si on avait doublé le budget
est-ce qu'on serait allé deux fois plus
vite je pense que ça c'est voilà ça ça
m'intéresserait d'avoir votre tour et
puis peut-être donc vous avez parlé du
crédit d'impôt du cite qui a été
transformé ensuite en prime rénov
d'avoir peut-être puisque voilà d'avoir
les deux les deux aspects et de voir un
petit peu ce que vous pensez par rapport
à cette modification et puis peut-être à
travers ça moi c'est peut-être le
sentiment que j'ai sur l'évolution de
ces différentes politiques publiques et
de ce qu'on peut faire c'est que c'est
souvent un peu un empilage et qu'on a un
peu du mal souvent à faire un peu un
bilan et c'est un peu le but justement
de cette commission d'enquête de ce qui
a été mis en place de l'efficacité ou
non et quand on vient rajouter à chaque
fois un petit peu une couche et du coup
on arrive à quelque chose qui est qui
est parfois un petit peu éligible donc
ça m'intéresserait d'avoir peut-être
votre votre avis en tout cas sur ce sur
cet aspect là
et sur voilà le dispositif prime rénov
ma prime rénov aujourd'hui savoir si
c'est vrai que les dernières
rapports qu'on a pu qu'on a pu avoir et
on s'aperçoit quand même que même s'il y
a eu à la fois la fonctionné il y a eu
pas mal d'argent dépensé on s'aperçoit
qu'on reste quand même sur des gestes
encore très très simple vous avez parlé
des fenêtres mais voilà mais ça peut
être les chaudières aussi et qu'on se
retrouve quand même sur des éléments
très
très faibles en termes en termes
d'intervention voilà globalement et puis
peut-être pour laisser quand même la
place mes collègues sur votre peut-être
votre vision sur l'appréciation et
l'évolution de la politique de
rénovation énergétique c'est à dire que
sur sur les perspectives et les
orientations qui peuvent être données et
sur ce qui peut être mis en place avoir
un petit peu votre votre sentiment par
rapport à par rapport à ça
c'est vrai que notamment on a pu avoir
quelques interventions sur le fait que
de dire que
on obtenait peut-être pas forcément
toujours les résultats qu'on aurait pu
penser quoi voilà et donc peut-être
avoir aussi cette vision là merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors d'abord moi
je pense qu'en matière d'écologie c'est
particulièrement vrai sur le logement il
faut viser des changements profonds
c'est pas c'est sûr que ça peut pas être
juste des des petits changements qui
vont régler le problème des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre si on prend ce
problème là qui est problème majeur qui
ne l'oublions pas grosso modo logement
tertiaire en France c'est à peu près un
tiers des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc c'est quand même un des
sujets majeurs avec les transports et
moi je crois depuis toujours
que c'est des changements pour qu'il
soit profond il faut qu'il soit durable
mais pour qu'il soit durable il faut
qu'il soit progressif moi je ne crois
pas au changement brutaux c'est à dire
d'un seul coup on va
imposer une règle qui va tout changer ça
je et alors c'est particulièrement vrai
dans le domaine du logement parce que
dans le domaine du logement on touche à
une des choses essentielles pour les
Français
que les gens d'ailleurs en soi
propriétaire ou locataires mais c'est
encore plus vrai quand ils en sont
propriétaires et ont tout on se heurte à
quelque chose on voit d'ailleurs que si
on intègre pas ça dans la réflexion
on aura toujours du mal à penser des
choses efficaces on se heurte à quelque
chose qui est que dans la tête de
beaucoup de propriétaires qui occupent
leur logement
encore aujourd'hui il est tout à fait
logique
d'investir de l'argent pour faire ce
qu'on appelle une rénovation mais une
rénovation on va dire d'agrément mais
c'est pas un jugement de valeur c'est
tout à fait bien de se sentir bien dans
son logement donc
les peintures les sols la cuisine la
salle de bain on investit facilement des
sommes importantes quelqu'un qui achète
d'ailleurs une maison et si vous en avez
fait le test ou sans doute vérifier
d'ailleurs les agents immobiliers même
ah oui oui voilà il y a 100000 € de
travaux voilà il y a 50.000 euros et ça
paraît pas du tout choquant et on fait
un budget et puis voilà et on a jamais
réussi à avoir le même raisonnement sur
l'efficacité énergétique
et y compris des gens qui sont sensibles
à gazon ils ont moins ce raisonnement là
il ne raisonne pas en termes d'agrément
autour alors que un logement bien isolé
est un logement plus agréable à vivre
mais c'est comme ça donc il faut
d'ailleurs il faudrait travailler
là-dessus il y a un autre élément par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit moi je
crois qu'il faut dire les choses
clairement en France on aime bien les
crédits d'impôts particulièrement sur le
logement je parle des citoyens
et j'ai aussi suivi les politiques du
logement pendant plus de 10 ans dans les
deux premiers mandats députés dès que
vous avez resserré l'accès au crédit
d'impôt pour l'investissement locatif ça
c'est sinon effondré en tout cas ça
fortement baissé c'est comme ça et donc
on peut dire c'est pas bien c'est bien
là les budgets d'air de Bercy il déteste
les crédits d'impôts puisque évidemment
c'est une dépense en plus qui n'est pas
limitée c'est un droit donc évidemment
une fois que c'est parti il faut payer
mais c'est efficace c'est à dire que ça
déclenche parce que les Français
n'aiment pas les impôts tout simplement
mais notamment l'impôt sur le revenu
mais bon ça c'est un autre débat et je
les comprends d'ailleurs mais ça c'est
une appréciation personnelle autre
problème c'est qui fait
on voit bien qu'on se heurte alors c'est
plus vrai sur le logement individuel
mais ça peut parfois être vrai sur des
copropriétés privées enfin c'est vrai
aussi sur les copropriétés privées à qui
va déjà la première impulsion faire un
audit énergétique même pas la peine de
dépenser des sons mais quand même un
audit énergétique pas simplement un DP
pas simplement un diagnostic de
performance énergétique qu'est-ce qui
cloche sur mon logement qu'est-ce qui
serait prioritaire qu'est-ce qui serait
le plus efficace ainsi de suite bon
c'est difficile d'imposer de dire si
vous voulez avoir un crédit d'impôt faut
d'abord avoir fait ça mais ce serait
quand même un sujet de réflexion mais si
on disait ça qui fait
alors sans doute certains s'en
souviennent à une époque ça a l'air
d'être moins d'ailleurs à la mode
aujourd'hui mais il faut bien le dire
des majorités de gauche j'en ai fait
partie donc c'est pas du tout
une critique mais ont beaucoup phosphoré
sur le service public de l'efficacité
énergétique
sp2e ça a du même être mis dans une loi
bon
moi je l'ai jamais cru ça je vous le dis
tout de suite parce que je crois pas que
son multipliant les services publics
divers et variés que sur un sujet qui
est aussi différent d'un Français à
l'autre d'une région à l'autre etc que
ça va être efficace il faudrait recruter
des des dizaines de milliers de
personnes partout sur les territoires
pour faire moi j'ai été regardé quand
j'étais ministre des expériences très
concrètes je me souviens d'une
communauté de communes qui avait fait
quelque chose de très bien mais elle
traitait sans logement par an une
communauté de communes de plus de 50 000
habitants pas une petite communauté de
communes donc c'est elle avait elle-même
évalué que sur son territoire si on
faisait ça il y en avait pour 100 ans
exagère peut-être un peu mais à peine
donc moi j'avais plaidé mais je n'ai pas
été suivi je dois le dire quand j'ai été
ministre pour une solution qui a aux
yeux de certains apparaisserait
peut-être comme libéral une je l'assume
totalement de faire appel à des
opérateurs privés c'est à dire de dire
voilà on dit on lance on appelle Love on
fait des lots parce que c'est 50 000
logements parce que c'est 100000
logements puisqu'on dit qu'on veut en
faire 500000 par an ça souvent été
l'objectif on dit voilà on fait 5 lots
de 100 000 kilos de 50 000 et c'est des
gens ils seront rémunérés sur le
résultat résultat en émission de gaz à
effet de serre économiser et en
performance énergétique et eux ils vont
s'occuper de faire l'audit énergétique
de conseiller les gens en travaux
éventuellement ils vont s'occuper
d'ailleurs de faire les travaux pour le
compte du propriétaire et c'est eux qui
géreront également les subventions ça
existe
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai inventé
dans ma petite tête on le fait pour on
l'a fait pour certains qui ont bénéficié
à l'époque c'était un euro la chaudière
ou autre il y a une société je préfère
de publicité il y en a d'autres qui
s'appelle les filles qui fait ça alors
on m'a dit NON NON même dans un
gouvernement comme celui de Monsieur
Macron il dit non non non non oh là là
on va pas faire appel à des privés on va
confier ça à la nappe l'Agence Nationale
pour l'Amélioration de l'Habitat
je change jamais je la connais la nage
les pratiquais quand j'étais élu local
très bien elle sait très bien faire sur
les copropriétés dégradées quelque chose
de très très approfondie très subtil
mais en très petit nombre et ça n'a pas
raté d'ailleurs on a augmenté les
crédits pour la norme mais ça n'a pas
suivi en réalisation
bon là aussi je ne dis pas que c'est une
recette miracle mais je pense qu'on
devrait quand même creuser cela et
dernier point vous avez évoqué et ça
c'est vrai que j'ai oublié d'en parler
alors que ça a été un élément majeur là
qui jouait à fond sur la symbolique
quand j'étais ministre
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
le Premier ministre c'est pas moi qui
m'exprime c'est le premier ministre
Édouard Philippe dit un jour dans une
interview à la radio dans une matinale
voilà nous envisageons de sortir du
fioul de sortir des chaudières au fioul
dans les logements individuels à
l'époque je pense que les chiffres n'ont
pas tellement changé 3 millions de
logements individuels chauffés au fioul
sans compter chaufferies collectives au
fioul y compris dans des bâtiments
publics y compris dans des mairies qui
se disent très à la pointe sur le sujet
et donc on dit ça et on dit d'ailleurs
c'est une image c'est 3 millions de
petites centrales thermiques on veut
supprimer les centrales thermiques tout
le monde est d'accord là-dessus on peut
le faire les logements les solutions
existent
pompe à chaleur le gaz là où il y a du
gaz haute performance meilleur rendement
ou le bois
et là surprise
si vous avez le temps mais il a été un
peu traumatisé par cet épisode tous les
général comment on veut nous interdire
c'était sortir avec été réinterprété
comme interdiction en gros ce qu'on
disait ça ne peut plus en réinstaller
évidemment on va aller on va pas aller
arracher une chaudière au fioul chez
quelqu'un en disant maintenant obligé de
la remplacer par autre chose et bien ça
c'était intolé y compris au sein du
gouvernement c'est un bon expliqué que
leurs parents étaient très attachés
aujourd'hui donc on a
on a stoppé net on s'est revenu après
mais je vois bien d'ailleurs que c'est
pas parce que ça revient que c'est réglé
mais quand même heureusement parce que
ce sont des actes concrets et là il y a
pas besoin de faire un audit énergétique
très puissant il y a au moins lorsque
les chaudières tombent pas moi je dis
pas forcément des chaudières qu'on
disant les mets à la poubelle et on en
place mais
chaudière elles arrivent en fin de vie
au moment où les remplacements c'est
plus possible mais à l'époque simplement
ça alors en plus c'était à l'époque
l'argument qui emporte et tout vous
allez remettre des gilets jaunes sur les
ronds-points voilà le mouvement de
défense des chaudières après tout ça ne
se fait pas en un jour c'est pas
toujours facile mais expliquer comme je
l'ai entendu à l'époque qu'il y avait
des gens pour qu'il y avait pas de
solution
c'est pas vrai
solution technique existe oui ne pompe à
chaleur c'est plus cher oui une
chaudière à gaze haute performance c'est
plus cher oui il y a pas du gaz partout
mais il y a quand même de l'électricité
partout dans notre pays et il y a le
bois qui est une ressource en plus qui
peut être française et bien ça à
l'époque ça n'a pas ça c'était un regret
que nous n'ayons pas pu avancer plus
vite encore une fois il s'agissait pas
d'interdire du jour au lendemain etc
c'est toujours des choses qu'on fait
progressivement mais qui sont ensuite
des changements durables et utiles
bref maximum un petit quart d'heure donc
j'ouvre les questions à nos collègues
membres de la commission s'il souhaite
poser des questions à Monsieur le
Ministre
oui Sabine Draxler
merci alors monsieur le ministre je
voudrais vous interroger plus
particulièrement sur l'articulation
entre la rénovation énergétique et le
patrimoine le petit patrimoine
majoritairement non protégée qui est
composé de construction d'avant en 1948
alors on réalise aujourd'hui quand vous
l'en luttez contre les passoires
thermiques et énergétiques qu'on a mis
en place des législations qui produisent
l'effet inverse je veux parler
déréglementation thermique et
environnementale avec un DPE inadapté
qui est conjugué au dispositions d'Usan
qui sont jusqu'àastrophiques pour le
patrimoine pour le patrimoine bâti
alors on le dit pas assez on met
beaucoup de patrimoine anciens sont
naturellement conçus pour être des
bâtiments intelligents par rapport au
climat donc je voulais vous demander si
vous estimez que l'urgence écologique
justifie que l'on fasse fit de la
conservation du patrimoine bâti ancien
est-ce que vous pensez que les
performances énergétiques de ce type de
bâti et ses qualités en termes d'inertie
sans suffisamment connu et prise en
compte
oui
je vais répondre du
moi je ne crois pas qui est de
contradiction systématique et majeure
entre la conservation du patrimoine je
suis moi-même attaché et la rénovation
énergétique je note d'ailleurs qu'on a
une vision aujourd'hui sans doute plus
conservatrice d'ailleurs du patrimoine
que les générations mais quand j'ai
générations sur plusieurs siècles
précédentes quand vous regardez certains
bâtiments devant lesquels on s'extasie à
juste titre si je prends au hasard le
Château des Ducs de Bretagne à Nantes
vous voyez qu'en fait c'est un c'est un
panorama de plusieurs époques et qu'on a
greffé des bâtiments de d'époque
successives sur les bâtiments originels
parfois en détruisait d'ailleurs sans
vergogne ça c'est tout à fait
regrettable et c'est tant mieux mais
enfin il faut pas je pense pas qu'il
faut qu'on bascule dans quelque chose de
totalement figé je regrette je le dis au
passage parce que ça ça c'est une
contrainte en effet qui est bien réelle
les règles que l'on prend au niveau
national que soit par la loi ou par des
décrets et puis il y a ensuite
l'interprétation qui en effet tout
l'application qui en est faite sur tous
les territoires de France avec notamment
les architectes des bâtiments de France
qui sont quand même très souvent très
restrictifs ou des réglementations
contradictoires entre elles j'ai connu à
une époque où on interdisait les
isolation par l'extérieur au motif que
ça faisait 20 cm ou 10 cm qui sur le
trottoir donc en fait on enlevait une
partie de l'espace public au profit il
faut quand même qu'on évolue sur ces
règles-là si on veut aboutir sur
l'efficacité rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments et puis à l'impossible nul
n'est tenues si vraiment il y a des
bâtiments que l'on ne peut absolument
pas modifier et qui doivent rester en
état malgré leur plus ou moins bonne
performance énergétique c'est moi ça me
paraît pas très grave je veux dire s'il
ne reste plus que des vieilles chapelles
des des vieux manoirs ou des vieux
château qui vraiment n'auront pas été
rénovés
dans les passoires thermiques si tentait
qu'elle le soit d'ailleurs c'est pas
très grave mais traitant tout le reste
et que ce ne soit pas un prétexte pour
ne pas traiter le reste des affreux
bâtiments disons-le voilà c'est un point
de vue personnel les années 70 ou
d'autres époques qui gagneraient à être
rénovés je le dis là franchement tel que
je le pense par l'extérieur quand je
vois qu'on refuse à certains endroits
enfin il y a des copropriétés qui refont
une façade qui refont la peinture d'une
façade et qui ne se pose même pas la
question de faire une isolation par
l'extérieur alors que ce serait un gain
immédiat pour baisser leurs factures de
chauffage moi j'ai même vu des
copropriétés qui avaient plus du coup
remplacer leur chaudière en achetant des
chaudières moins puissantes puisqu'il y
avait moins besoin de chauffer et donc
il faisait une économie non seulement au
fonctionnement mais aussi un
investissement de départ mais il fallait
évidemment avoir ce raisonnement dès le
départ si on tronçonne les choses et
qu'on dit on va faire la chaudière un
jour puis on va faire la peinture de la
façade d'un autre jour puis les fenêtres
encore un autre jour ainsi de suite mais
évidemment on ne regarde pas le bénéfice
global d'un bâtiment d'une rénovation
énergétique d'un bâtiment
oui
merci beaucoup madame présidente
je suis le président mais moi je j'ai
retenu quelque chose qui va
intéresser parce que c'est quelque chose
que nous vivons tous les jours c'est le
fait que en ayant supprimé le crédit
d'impôt
les
personnes qui possède des logements
locatifs comme un revenu sont en train
effectivement de les mettre sur le
marché parce qu'elles ne veulent pas les
rénover pour une raison simple c'est que
comme le pays des impôts
n'auront pas de déduction fiscale n'ont
pas droit à la prime rénov
puisque elles sont au dessus des
plafonds et donc moi je me demandais si
on pouvait pas avoir gardé la prime
rénov pour les ménages en précarité et
refaire un peu le crédit d'impôt parce
que là notamment dans la montagne où on
demande des normes extrêmement
importantes les agents immobiliers
d'ailleurs nous nous préviennent tous
les logements petit à petit ne pourront
plus être loués parce que effectivement
quand on fait le bilan énergétique voilà
et les propriétaires disent on va vendre
quelqu'un le fera ce que vous avez dit
d'ailleurs moi je pense que c'est un peu
dangereux tout ce qui va se passer et je
pense que si on rétablissait le crédit
d'impôts il y aurait une solution pour
une partie de la population qui possède
des logements parce que sinon ils vont
disparaître du marché et comme par
ailleurs on en construit pas beaucoup
ça va poser un problème assez rapidement
voilà
oui alors il faut quand même dire que
sans rentrer dans la technique qui a
quand même un dispositif qui existe pour
les propriétaires bailleurs c'est quand
ils font des travaux ils peuvent déduire
le montant des travaux de leurs revenus
locatifs et ça c'est mémoire je crois
sur plusieurs années donc c'est quand
même quelque chose il y a d'ailleurs des
gens qui savent très bien jouer avec ça
mais c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait sain puisque ça correspond à une
réalité c'est j'investis ensuite je loue
mais ça a un coût d'investir donc je
déduis les travaux le montant des
travaux des revenus locatifs mais ça ne
suffit pas toujours par rapport à ce qui
est puis et puis c'est aussi ça il faut
faire avec la mentalité d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens propriétaires
bailleurs qui ne veulent pas faire
travaux mais ça énergies ou pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas que sur l'énergie
et qui parfois préfère vendre après
c'est aussi la logique du marché c'est
un moment donné si quelqu'un dit bah moi
je préfère récupérer l'argent que vaut
mon logement plutôt que de loyer et puis
je vais investir l'argent chaude c'est
la vie si d'autres le font parce que si
en revanche personne ne le fait alors là
ou si c'est des propriétaires occupants
qui du coup par un logement de très
mauvaise performances on aura rien gagné
donc il faut trouver des dispositifs qui
soient adaptés mais je pense que ça a
plus très en fait à la je sais que
certains plaident pour qu'il y ait un
statut peut-être de l'investisseur
immobilier comme est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs enfin c'est à regarder mais
pour que ce soit plus attractif de de
faire des travaux l'investissement c'est
pas que l'achat dans le 9 c'est aussi
des travaux dans l'ancien au passage je
précise que j'ai dû également mener la
bataille mais je pense que mes
prédécesseurs à mes successeurs
également sur la TVA à 5,5 puisque très
souvent et quasiment tous les ans les
ministres de l'économie et des finances
essayent de revenir sur la TVA 5,5 pour
les travaux
d'amélioration des logements et je crois
que c'est c'est un dispositif lui aussi
alors on peut dire peut-être ça se fait
perverse mais c'est quelque chose qui
fera plaisirs et qui donc est une petite
incitation aussi en tout cas si la TVA
était montée ce serait sans aucun doute
une des
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour un certain
nombre d'éclairs sismant que vous avez
apporté aujourd'hui moi j'avais une
question sur l'efficacité dont vous nous
avez beaucoup parlé en fait on avait le
sentiment que c'est véritablement votre
objectif
en revanche je me pose malgré tout une
question c'est que cette efficacité
puisque on parle aujourd'hui de logement
de c'est de ça dont il est question on
sait que lorsque nous avons une bonne
isolation nous avons moins de
consommation d'énergie je dirais c'est
le baba que tout le monde peut
comprendre c'est ce cette moindre
consommation d'énergie peut avoir deux
incidences c'est à dire soit
effectivement c'est au bénéfice de
l'environnement et là on est dans une
constance et quelque chose que l'on peut
véritablement
identifier très clairement soit
évidemment ça peut avoir un jouet aussi
un
bénéfice sur le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens là pour le coup on est sur
un sujet un peu plus fluctuant du prix
des énergies quel que soit l'énergie et
ainsi de suite et je sens aussi dans vos
propos qu'il y avait en fait un certain
nombre de tensions au sein même du
gouvernement lorsqu'il s'agissait
peut-être pour vous de convaincre vos
collègues peut-être même le président de
la République et je me posais la
question mais alors sur quel élément sur
quel expertise sur quelle étude d'impact
vous vous
adociez vous même en tant que ministre
ou le gouvernement dans son entièreté
pour pouvoir arbitrer une décision et
aller plutôt dans un sens ou dans un
autre est-ce que vous pourriez aussi
nous apporter des éléments là dessus je
vous remercie
oui d'abord c'est c'est tout le temps
comme ça dans un gouvernement et moi je
trouve ça normal d'ailleurs c'est
l'inverse qui serait étonnant il y avait
toujours les journalistes ah bon vous
avez perdu l'arbitrage ceci cela
malheureusement qu'il y a des
discussions et des négociations des
négociations c'est pas un gros mot
d'ailleurs le mot négociation ça veut
pas dire qu'un gagnant et un perdant
d'ailleurs ça veut dire que bah on
essaye de trouver un compromis entre des
objectifs qui sont parfois différents et
qui pourtant sont tous d'intérêt sur le
logement je n'accuse pas le ministre du
Logement de ne pas de n'avoir rien voulu
faire lui il avait son objectif de dire
il faut qu'elle maximum de logements à
la vente et à la location enfin
construction d'une part et en location
d'autre part c'est un objectif tout à
fait louable je pense qu'on le partage
tous après est-ce qu'on le met devant
l'objectif climatique est-ce qu'il est
contradictoire ça bah ça c'est les
discussions c'est normal et
contrairement à ce que croit plein de
gens et et ce que propage les médias ou
autres c'est évidemment pas le président
de la République qui décide tout seul
il passe son temps d'abord à laisser son
premier ministre arbitrer et puis aussi
à arbitrer des choses avec des
des arguments qui viennent de ces
différents ministres et même quand tu
décides quelque chose d'ailleurs parfois
les ministres ensuite le Road tricote
alors façon et voilà c'est c'est normal
on est en démocratie on n'est pas dans
le pouvoir de droit divin ou de droit
purement présidentiel sur les critères
oui on prend des décisions sur la base
de d'un certain nombre d'études et de
mesure et en la matière il y en a
énormément alors il faut les renouveler
parce que ça bouge tant mieux d'ailleurs
les passoires énergétiques on les a
défini on a quand même tout un travail
qui a été fait de définition d'un
certain nombre de critères alors on voit
bien le DPE Diagnostic de Performance
magique on l'a revu etc bon voilà donc
ça permet de prendre des décisions un
peu éclairées
après je vous l'ai dit au début parfois
on subit une pression médiatique
médiatico-politique voilà les deux sont
quand même très imbriqués qui fait que
on va finalement plutôt aller dans un
sens ou plutôt aller dans l'autre bon
sur la question du logement il y a
énormément de choses qui rentrent en
ligne de compte bien sûr il y a
énormément de types de logements donc
chaque fois qu'on dit ah mais vous allez
porter atteinte à la personne retraitée
qui vit dans un pavillon construit dans
les années 70 dans les Ardennes et que
je sais pas si j'en ai eu des Ardennes
ici mais j'ai entendu cela et c'est vrai
à l'époque maintenant ça peut être
encore changé mais le prix du logement
était très bas donc on me disait vous
allez faire un des logements quand une
valeur négative
dans l'absolu on pouvait même aller
jusqu'à cette situation bon sachant
qu'il y en a qui avait deux faites une
valeur négative aux voisines de zéro
sans cela c'est à dire qu'il restait sur
le marché à la vente pendant des années
parce que de toute façon personne ne
voulait les acheter donc ça c'était un
autre problème et tout ça venait ce
mélanger donc c'est très varié est-ce
que ça ne nous contraint à ne rien faire
non moi je crois qu'il y a toujours un
chemin pour l'action si on prend en
compte les différents choix et si on
accepte que une direction prise des
différentes mesures ne vont pas répondre
d'entrée de jeu à toutes les situations
ça explique la complexité et
l'empilement je sais plus qui en a parlé
tout à l'heure des mesures parce que oui
pour faire face à des situations
différentes on empile des dispositifs
différents et parfois on simplifie mais
vous avez vu là aussi régulièrement il y
a des mouvements on dit faut simplifier
alors on simplifie qu'est-ce qui se
passe à chaque fois c'est la même chose
soit on simplifie tellement que ça fait
une dépense énorme parce que plein de
gens c'est formidable c'est très simple
alors allons-y et je vais bénéficier du
crédit d'impôt de la prime rénov ou de
la subvention etc et donc en général il
y a un tour de vis dans l'autre sens
après ou c'est tellement c'est tellement
simplifié bah ça ne couvre plus la
diversité des situations donc les gens
s'en plaignent donc faut assumer qu'il y
a une part de complexité et évidemment
il faut un peu accompagner les gens mais
sur des critères que l'on a le critère
CO2 alors par exemple ça c'est un sujet
concret c'est pas tout à fait le même
critère le critère émission de gaz à
effet de serre que le critère
dépense énergétique
c'est pas tout à fait la même mesure on
a eu un débat et il se poursuivra il se
poursuit encore on a modifié d'ailleurs
je crois c'est pas moi quand j'étais
ministre mais on l'avait préparé là
c'était sur le neuf mais sur le
chauffage électrique c'est vrai qu'il y
a une époque je crois paradoxalement
d'ailleurs que c'était sous le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy on a
objectivement alourdi très fortement par
un mode de calcul un peu artificiel ce
qu'on pensait que l'impact CO2 d'un
chauffage électrique ce qui fait que on
a construit plein de logements neufs
avec des chauffages au gaz voir à
certains endroits d'ailleurs la même
refait des choses chaudière au fioul ça
n'était pas logique et dans un logement
c'est toujours pareil dans un logement
très bien isolé moi je pense que le
chauffage électrique est assez adapté
puisque il y a moins besoin de puissance
c'est plus ponctuel etc et ça en France
avec un bilan CO2 voisins de zéro enfin
très très faible donc mais à d'autres
endroits ce sera peut-être moins vrai
parce que on aura justement moins fait
d'isolation et ainsi de suite donc de ce
point de vue là je pense que on peut
tout à fait prendre des mesures et en en
tout cas moi quand j'étais y compris les
négociés des discussions entre Nice
elles étaient fondées sur des sur des
évaluations chiffrées n'étaient pas
fondées comme ça juste sur des
impressions
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
peut-être vraiment la dernière question
parce que je crois qu'on a le dame
Ségolène Royal qui est arrivé
donc la parole j'en ai merci à vous
présente juste une question à Monsieur
Miss avec votre fibre écologique parce
qu'on parle d'économie d'énergie mais on
parle pas d'économie d'énergie durable
c'est à dire que tout le temps on a dit
aux gens vous pouvez faire des communes
énergies c'est du polystyrène c'est du
polyuréthane c'est de la laine de verre
et qu'à un moment donné il y a jamais eu
de différenciation pour donner
subventions supplémentaires
cités un peu plus écolos ou du chanvre
et autres et aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
pensez que ça va un jour changer parce
qu'on est quand même dans un
raisonnement très chimique des économies
ou des économies d'énergie et pas dans
un raisonnement de développement durable
alors moi je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je pense que si on met trop de
critères le mieux éliminé du bien on
aura une rénovation que ça a tellement
formidable avec que des matériaux
biosourcés etc que 1 elle sera plus cher
quand même et de il y en aura beaucoup
moins y compris parce que il y aura
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de moins de
gens qui seront capables de
l'appréhender quand je dis l'appender
c'est le propriétaire qui se lance dans
les travaux comme l'artisan qui réalise
les artisans qui réalisent les travaux
pour autant le bilan énergétique global
en effet d'une construction comme d'une
rénovation il peut parfaitement être
fait et je pense que là c'est un autre
travail à faire là aussi sans doute
progressif mais bon voilà je dis ça
comme je le pense qu'en effet un jour ou
l'autre quand même on pourra se passer
de la laine de verre et que c'est pas
très rationnel en effet de continuer bon
c'est souvent parce que quand même c'est
moins cher voilà c'est pour ça vous le
polystyrène ou le polluenin mais oui à
terme je pense qu'on est tout à fait
capable de remplacer ces matériaux qui
eux-mêmes ont un impact carbone
important dans de fabrication qui sont
issus de produits par ailleurs souvent
pétroliers fossiles pour avoir des
choses qui soient avec un bilan
écologique global qui soit meilleur ça
c'est sûr mais si on veut le faire tout
de suite et qu'on met toutes ces
conditions là à l'obtention d'aide par
exemple pour faire des travaux on risque
d'avoir relativement peu de travaux
réalisés
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre de
cette édition et on vous souhaite une
bonne soirée
merci à vous et bon travaux